let's solve 350 divided by 50 so one way
to think about this is if we have 350 of
something let's say something delicious
like brownies if we had 350 brownies and
we were dividing them into groups of 50
how many groups of 50 could we get well
one idea is to count by 50s until we get
to 350 and see how many groups there are
one group of 50 would be 50 plus another
group of 50 would be a hundred plus
another group of 50 is 150 another one
will be 200 200 plus 50 is 250 plus
another 50 is 300 and plus one more 50
is 350 so when we added all these 50s
these groups of 50 50 100 150 200 250
300 350 we ended up with 350 so 350 can
be divided into this many groups of 50
and how many groups is this 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 so 350 divided into groups of 50 is 7
now let's look at that quotient that's
solution of 7 and let's notice something
if we had simply divided 35 by 5 we
would have also gotten 735 divided into
groups of 5 is also equal to 7 so in a
way these zeroes didn't matter they
didn't affect our answer we were able to
cancel them out having the zero in the
first number is cancelled out by having
that zero in the second number and let's
look at why that is let's think about
why that is division is really the same
as a fraction so if we wrote this as a
fraction let's say 350 over 50
well this fraction bar right here is the
same as the division sign up here 350
/ 50 is the same as 350 over 50 and when
we have a fraction like this fraction
down here we can simplify it in this
case because there's zeros on the end we
know they're both multiples of 10 so we
can divide them both by 10 we can divide
our numerator and our denominator by 10
and when we divide whole numbers by 10
we have a trick we can use a pattern
really which is that the whole number in
this case 350 when it's divided by 10 we
drop a zero from the end so 350 divided
by 10 is 35 350 could be divided into
ten groups of 35 and then 50 divided by
10 will be the same thing when we divide
50 by 10 we drop that zero off the end
or another way to think about it is 50
divided into groups of 10 would make 5
groups and then we end up with our
simplified fraction of 35 fifths or 35
divided by 5 which is the same thing
here so in both of these cases we can
see that 350 divided by 50 is the same
as 35 divided by 5 so in both whole
numbers when we're dividing whole
numbers and they both end in zeros we
can cancel those zeros basically we're
factoring out of 10 we're taking the 10
the divided by 10 out of both of them
out of both numbers so we can cancel
those zeros which leaves us with smaller
numbers and at least for me I find
division a lot simpler when I'm working
with smaller numbers let's try a few
more
let's try one like 420 divided by 70 so
we can see we have two whole numbers
both end in zero so we're gonna cancel
those zeros basically we're dividing a
10 out of both
numbers and end up with a simpler
division problem of 42 divided by 7 42
divided by 7 equals 6
therefore 420 divided by 70 also equals
6 and here's one last one what if we had
five thousand six hundred or fifty six
hundred divided by 80 so the first thing
I notice is I have zeros at the end of
both of my whole numbers if I cancel out
this one I can cancel out one on the
other side I can't cancel both of them
over here there were two canceling we
have to cancel the same amount of zeros
on both sides and now we end up with 560
divided by eight this leaves us with a
new division problem that's still a
little bit tricky but easier than
dividing by eighty so here we can think
of 560 as 56 tens because of the zero on
the end and 56 tens or 560 could be
re-written as 10 times 56 these are
equivalent 560 and 10 times 56 because
10 times 56 is a 56 with a zero on the
end and rewriting it this way makes it
so now I have a division problem right
here 56 divided by 8 that we can solve
56 divided by 8 is 7 and then we still
have this 10 and the time sign and 10
times 7 equals 70 so our solution here
when we divided 560 by 8 was 70 so that
means our solution up here for 5,600
divided by 80 is also 70 because when we
cancel zeroes and divide we still get
the same solution
but remember we have to cancel the same
amount of zeros in each number here we
couldn't cancel both zeros if we cancel
one zero in the dividend we can cancel
one zero in the divisor and another
thing to remember about this trick first
thing to remember is we need to cancel
the same amount of zeros and the second
the zeros have to be at the end of the
problem so if we had a division problem
something for example like 506 divided
by 20 here we cannot cancel the zeros we
cannot cancel the zeros because this
zero is not on the end so the new
problem this would give us 56 divided by
two is not equivalent does not equal the
top division problem so we can't cancel
zeros that does not work we cannot
cancel zeros unless they're at the end
of the problem and we cancel the same
amount in both the dividend and the
divisor